samantha
i'm i know who you are
i've been through this
a lot
this is your life now which means that
whoever this is is going to keep coming
for you
you ready
for this
never so the original scream celebrated
20 its 25th anniversary when did you
realize scream was gonna become an
iconic horror film
it took me a minute to realize that but
i think you know obviously when the film
was doing very well in the first few
first month um and the box office kind
of flew and i probably when i saw the
first ghostface costume yeah that was
when i really realized that it was
becoming an iconic film uh what was your
favorite scream kill in the franchise
well it's not my favorite it's the
saddest it's tatum my sister gets it
though yeah but it's also
brutal it was it was great yeah garage
killing is always nice in the door
okay what makes sydney galen doing such
a strong trio how have they survived
ghost space all this time
i think because you're a badass and yeah
you're really smart stay close
don't leave or don't stay close
what line from scream is quoted back to
you uh by fans the most hello sydney
that was a scary movie i'm dewey not
toofy
get it all the time
thank you
okay which scream character from the
past four movies do you wish had
survived to join you in the sequels
oh gosh there's a bunch but um
randy yeah randy randy was loved and and
funny and yeah he was but i gotta go
with my sister rose
[Laughter]
we've had scream killers uh terrorized
three generations now what advantages
does gen z have over gen x and
millennials when it comes to fighting
ghostface
which one is it now z
we must be
yeah gen z now i think well gen z will
just be like
[Laughter]
they won't even try they'll just be like
whatever i gotta excuse me you're gonna
kill me i just got to send this one
snapchat
[Laughter]
i don't know why they don't have low
voices i don't know why
what's your favorite romantic comedy
what's your favorite romantic question
that's not a serious question
when harry met sally you can't do it oh
no that's right yeah when hearing that's
right
who's your favorite ghost face reveal
from the past four movies
what's been the most memorable scene of
us together in the scream franchise
of us the three of us together sure my
favorite of us is when you change yeah
yeah other glasses like that and i
thought it worked well and she really
punched me which is weird
i was there too
yeah it was kind of yeah trying to help
out
thanks dewey
it still went down the first screen
established the rules for surviving a
horror movie how do you think the rules
have evolved i think because technology
has evolved you know 10 years ago it was
suddenly social media
and cell phones and uh it made it more
challenging for it to be uh
hard to find the killer and so that that
was more difficult to navigate in the
script and now the technology has
advanced more where you know in the even
in the trailer you can see that you can
lock house doors and unlock house doors
from an app so that shifted as well what
excited you the most about coming back
to scream after all these years
seeing you guys and getting back into
these characters
really it's really fun to the dynamic
amongst us and getting back into these
characters yeah yeah we seem to laugh a
lot yeah what horror film would you love
to have a scream crossover with
halloween versus ghost faces
mike myers
what's your favorite scary movie in the
last 10 years since screen four came out
wait since what was that there's harvey
your favorite horror film is it get out
get out maybe get out i loved ready or
not i really loved it
was great too uh for the new scream the
production recreated the killer's house
from the first film how did you react to
seeing that on set a lot of memories
flooded back was really emotional and it
was done such a great job and there was
one of the characters his name wes so
there was a post of a big sign i was
like ah he's right here and yeah
and yet he's not
and so it was it was emotional yeah
totally as a scream uh scream veterans
what advice did you have for the new
cast
nothing
so professional i was like they knew
what they were i still feel like they're
like a little more professional than me
everyone's more professional
[Music]
i mean there's no complaints or like
hours
[Music]
yeah
wes craven had such a lasting impact on
horror
uh what's your favorite memory of wes
craven while working on these films i
don't think there's any one favorite
memory i just i just
just he was such a gem and and loved
loved his energy and was such an honor
to be with him i love your memory can
you share your memory oh i'm on screen
for
wes got the giggles and he could not
stop
and he would sit him and they'd say you
know action and he sat there and all of
a sudden he just
couldn't stop laughing and i was
recording it and it just was the cutest
thing i've ever did you feel me yeah
oh my gosh that's amazing what was the
last day of shooting like i don't know
that any of us were there for the last
day of shooting i guess our last day of
shooting for me it felt it was emotional
uh just i think it always is when you
wrap a film but especially these ones
you know it's uh these movies mean a lot
to me so we shot it during covet so it
was really hard like you didn't really
get to meet the crew as well as you
typically would because we're not
staying in the same hotels and
you know that they all have masks on and
it was like this weird dynamic so i just
apologize for not getting to know him
better yeah that was the hard part yeah
what excites you most about a new
generation of horror fans seeing a new
scream or any scream for the first time
well what i think that really what's so
exciting about it is the scream is is
new it's a revitalized scream it is
scary it's gorier and um i think that
people will want to know what happened
in the first screen to see with these
characters and how they all tied
together and um so then i think we get
to start all over again i it's i love
that so
the 12 year olds are gonna know who yep
these characters aren't anyway
what character from any movie or show
you've played would most likely survive
a scream to
the guy from john's i'm gonna say for
you
wild things i think monica keller
i'd probably say gordy boggs the
wrestler from ready to roll
um how much of a problem do you think
cell phones were for ghost face
pro i mean
you know there's some benefits
and some disadvantages yes exactly so i
think he's gonna do all right with all
the technology yeah he's he's also
coming up with the time so he knows how
to work his own self hershey situation
how do you think horror films have
changed since the first screen i think
you know they got gory or definitely
after the first one was all the saw
films
and then even like midsummer they got
like abstract and insane get out was
incredible like cerebral palsy but there
haven't been any funny ones though have
there
not that aren't supposed to just be
straight comedy with a bit of scare i
don't think do you guys have a screen
playlist that you go to when you prepare
for this oil i was very well asked david
no i actually do i don't i don't i don't
have a screen one but yeah there's i
think there's
songs that bring you back to certain
times or or brings out certain emotions
um i think music is a is really
important i took singing lessons
for about
two weeks and as soon as i were like oh
why did i want to learn landslide okay i
couldn't get through the first line i'm
sorry this is all i just won't be able
to sing and i'm a terrible singer so it
wouldn't work out anyway
songs that bring you back to a certain
time yeah like
bring back certain memories
you